Stop trying to grow an audience. Every
guru is telling you to build your brand
and post consistently and grow your
following. And that advice is keeping
you broke because followers and likes
are vanity metrics. But you know what's
not? Revenue. Listen, the creators that
are winning right now are not the ones
with the biggest following. They are the
ones with the most loyal email list.
Think about it. Justin Welsh, Ali
Abdaal, Dan Koe. Listen, I've seen
people with 2,000 email subscribers
making 10 grand a month and I've seen
people with 200,000 YouTube subscribers
making nothing. And the difference is
one of them understands something that
the other one doesn't and it's not what
you think. Content does not create cash.
Copywriting does. Sales beat size every
time. So if you know how to grow, but
you don't know how to sell, then the
growth doesn't matter. But if you know
how to sell and you learn how to grow,
then you can create content for a
living.